[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber
büttenabend seit mittwoch rücken
türkische truppen in einen teil von
syrien vor in dem bisher relative ruhe
herrschte garantiert von kurdischen
truppen
gestützt von ihren amerikanischen
verbündeten bis donald trump begann die
abzuziehen
es sind doch nur 50 mann erklärte er
anfangs aber jetzt werden es 1000 und da
bleibt nichts mehr von der us-präsenz
außer twitter drohungen aus dem weißen
haus
das chaos das die kritiker der türkei
und der us-politik vorhergesagt haben
beginnt sich zu entfalten in einem
gebiet das noch angeblich türkische
sicherheitszone werden soll
lück wallbott berichtet seit fünf tagen
feiert die türkische armee mit voller
kraft auf ziele jenseits der grenze nach
kurdischen angaben nutzten inhaftierte
terroristen des sogenannten islamischen
staates das chaos um aus einem gefängnis
auszubrechen wie dieses video einer
überwachungskamera belegen soll einiges
kämpfer seien hier entkommen heißt es
außerdem dschihadisten selbst sind dabei
weitere 80.000 familienangehörige und
unterstützer in lagern im kampfgebiet
interniert davon viele europäische
staatsangehörige aus einem der lager in
einer fluren heute mehrere hundert von
ihnen richtung süden
die aufnahmen im internet zeigen wir
müssen jetzt eben denise und die
türkischen angreifer kämpfen sagte der
kommandeur
unsere kräfte sind aber begrenzt
türkische soldaten und arabische
freischärler rückten heute weiter nach
osten vor und besetzten die grenzstadt
tel aviv
dabei kam es zu heftigen kämpfen mit
kurdischen kräften
unterdessen kündigte washington den
rückzug von bis zu 1000 us soldaten aus
der region an um nicht unter feuer zu
beraten
ich weiß nicht ob die türken auf uns
schießen würden aber es landeten schon
granaten in der nähe türken und kurden
bekriegten sich seit jahren twitterte
präsident trump da sei es sehr klug
nicht in die kämpfe verwickelt zu sein
die kurden zögen sich ja anscheinend
zurück das sei gut so der könnte tanning
der live netz inzwischen mehren sich
berichte über zivile opfer der angriffe
die arabischen freischärler sollen bei
einer straßensperre südlich von tel aviv
eine kurdische politikerin und ihre
begleiter brutal hingerichtet haben am
abend kündigte außerdem die assad
regierung in damaskus an noch heute
nacht truppen in den norden zu entsenden
um den türkischen einmarsch zu stoppen
deutschland und europa sind über all das
sehr besorgt und stemmen sich gegen
erdogans vorgehen mit allem was sie
haben
das war heute der vorschlag einige
rüstungsgüter für einige zeit nicht mehr
an die türkei zu liefern
nicht sehr eindrucksvoll verglichen mit
der twitter drohung von real donald
trump dass er bei unbotmäßigen verhalten
die wirtschaft der türkei restlos
zerstören werde aber das hat ja auch
nicht gewirkt arbeitsbesuch in paris es
sind viele themen über die angela merkel
und präsident mal kommt am abend
sprechen dragset europa handelskonflikte
vor allem aber die sorge um die kurden
und die türkische offensive im norden
von syrien
ich habe heute eine stunde mit dem
präsidenten erdogan gesprochen
es gibt natürlich prächtigste
sicherheitsinteressen der türkei aber
auch ich glaube und die bundesregierung
glaubt dass diese offensive beendet
werden muss weil die humanitären folgen
gravierend sind sicherheitsinteressen
damit begründet am abend im zdf auch der
türkische botschafter den einmarsch in
syrien
wir haben bisher mehr als 300 anschläge
aus diesem gebiet auskommen
richtig und perilya hier ist der
jüdische ableger pkk
das ist eine organisation auch in
deutschland verboten argumente die
international auf skepsis stoßen dass
die türkei in syrien auf westliche
waffensysteme einsetzt sorgt zusätzlich
für verärgerung berlin und paris haben
deshalb alle waffenexporte gestoppt der
opposition jedoch reicht das nicht
es kann nicht sein dass wir als deutsche
als europäer nur lasch reagieren sondern
hier müssen sehr klares stopp schild her
auf kritik aber reagiert erdogan gereizt
und droht
wenn ihr versucht unsere operation als
invasion darzustellen werden wir die
tore öffnen und 3,6 millionen
flüchtlinge zu euch schicken
naja erdogan hat gezeigt der staat ja
auch menschen ein dass er zu allem fähig
ist ich würde also eine drohung ernst
nehmen
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir jetzt
auch mal die muskeln spielen lassen und
da gibt es nur eins das ist die
wirtschaft da kann man ihn treffen oder
sollte man nie treffen
neben dem ende der rüstungsexporte
dürfte deshalb auch die frage der
sanktionen diskutiert werden wenn sich
morgen in luxemburg die eu
außenministertreffen in welche maßnahmen
ergreifen wir dass wir welche ergreifen
werden so wie deutschland und frankreich
das getan haben davon gehe ich aus das
ist sicher
und darüber hinaus wird man sich
sicherlich auch weitere optionen offen
halten je nachdem wie die türkei sich in
der kommenden zeit verhält viel zeit
bleibe jedoch nicht warnen experten
dabei betreffe der konflikt vor allem
die europäer
wir haben da aktien und angesichts der
tatsache wie groß unsere aktien sind
würde ich sagen ist unsere ohnmacht doch
sehr deutlich sichtbar und das ist nicht
nur militärischer um macht sondern auch
diplomatisch gemacht wonach die auch
kurdische demonstranten in berlin spüren
was sie fordern kaum mehr umstritten
darüber hinaus aber blatt uhr nur eine
vage hoffnung
heute hatten polen die wahl mehr als 30
millionen menschen waren aufgerufen ein
neues parlament und damit die zukünftige
regierung zu bestimmen
aus sicht der europäischen kommission
und fast alle eu-länder war das eine
chance eine regierung abzuwählen wie es
nicht so genau nimmt mit rechtsstaats
prinzipien wie freie presse und
unabhängiger justiz
entscheidend ist aber wie die mehrheit
der polen das sieht vor einer knappen
stunde kamen die ersten prognosen und
brachten einen deutlichen sieg der schon
bisher regierenden kies schotter
[Applaus]
diese woche boden mitten in deutschland
zwei arglose menschen von einem
fanatischen hasser ermordet sein
eigentliches ziel war ein blutbad unter
der jüdischen gemeinde von halle 80
jahre nach der reichsprogromnacht
sollten wieder frauen männer und kinder
sterben weil sie juden waren genau das
wovor extremismus fachleute seit jahren
warnen ein neues aufflammen von
mörderischen antisemitismus wenn
verächtlich machen der hasserfüllte
sprache in taten um schlägt dieses
argument richtete die debatte auch auf
die afd
deren rechtsnationaler flügel immer
wieder mit der grenze des sagbaren
spielt und die grenze über tritt die
partei verwahrt sich gegen den vorwurf
in ihrem programm stehen nicht ein
einziger antisemitischer gedanke
sie habe sogar juden in ihren reihen
diese auseinandersetzung beschäftigt
andreas maurer andrea pardon maurer und
david gibt solche parolen sind längst
wieder auf deutschen straßen zu hören
rechtsextreme 2018 in dortmund seit
halle ist klar den worten können taten
folgen
antisemitismus ist in deutschland wieder
mörderisch das hat sie heute auf berlins
straßen getrieben tausende demonstrieren
gegen antisemitismus und rassismus für
viele von ihnen ist auch die fdp des
problems fakt ist antisemitismus gehört
nicht zum markenkern der afd
doch einzelne parteimitglieder bedienen
verschwörungstheorien mit
auslegungsspielraum wie ein höcker etwa
spricht von einem internationalen geld
macht komplex mit seiner krakenhaften
machtstruktur dunkelmännern im
hintergrund juden nennt er nicht
explizit und doch bediene er alte
stereotype sagt ein antisemitismus
forscher meistens wird behauptet da
steckt der jude dahinter und
insbesondere hierbei werke der reiche
jude oder die reichen juden die regieren
alles und kontrollieren alles das ist
der evergreen oder er war braun der an
auch die mutter des attentäters von
halle folgt ein bei einem solchen
denkmuster im aktuellen spiegel wird sie
mit folgenden worten zitiert er hat
nichts gegen juden in dem sinn
er hat was gegen die leute die hinter
der finanziellen macht stehen wer hat
das nicht
antisemitische klischees wie diese sind
jahrhunderte alt so alt wie der
judenhass selbst im nationalsozialismus
führte er zum massenmord und doch suchen
afd vertreter immer wieder den
kalkulierten tabubruch sprechen von
schuldkult von dem recht stolz zu sein
auf die leistungen deutscher soldaten in
zwei weltkriegen konrad adam ist
gründungsmitglied der afd
er sieht solche aussagen seiner
parteifreunde kritisch dass man da es
sehr interessant macht ist vielleicht
das bewusste kalkül einiger leute dass
man damit allerdings ein gefährliches
spiel spielt da würde ich zustimmen und
deswegen wäre es gut wenn man diese
bewusst zweideutigen meinungen unter
ließe auch nach halle wird wieder
relativiert versucht das rechtsextreme
antisemitische motiv zu verharmlosen afd
mandatsträger schrieben nach dem terror
eine tat des wahnsinns keine politische
tat bin ja mal gespannt wer das in halle
inszeniert hat die zeit wird es zeigen
was ist schlimmer eine beschädigte
synagogen tür oder zwei getötete
deutsche solche meinungen werden in der
afg zumindest geduldet so wie bislang
wolfgang gedeon den seit jahren auch
parteiintern antisemitismus vorgeworfen
wird und der noch immer parteibuch und
unterstützer hat es laufend
parteiausschlussverfahren die sind
leider noch nicht abgeschlossen er dem
problem bei uns in unseren reihen
stellen wir uns kein politisches
lavieren relativieren mehr ein klares
bekenntnis zum nie wieder
das war die botschaft die heute von
berlins straßen ausging
[Musik]
nun die nachrichten von gundel ag in
japan hat einer der heftigsten taifune
seit jahrzehnten massive schäden
angerichtet
35 menschen verloren ihr leben
sintflutartige regenfälle haben ganze
landstriche unter wasser gesetzt
in der provinz nagano traten gewässer
über die ufer dämme brachen wohngebiete
wurden überflutet erdrutsche rissen
häuser und autos mit rund 100.000
rettungskräfte sind im einsatz und
suchen nach vielen vermissten
zehntausende japaner wurden in
notunterkünften untergebracht
gegen den sächsischen landesbischof
grenzen der bereits seinen rücktritt
angekündigt hat gibt es neue vorwürfe
heute bestätigte die sächsische
landeskirche dass der evangelische
theologe als student texte für die
rechte zeitschrift fragmente geschrieben
hatte
die als nationalistisch und
demokratiefeindlich einzustufen seien
der ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen
kirche in deutschland bedford strohm
forderte schnelle aufklärung nach
tagelangen protesten in ecuador wollen
die regierung und vertreter der
indigenen völker einen weg aus der krise
suchen
für den abend wurde ein erstes treffen
angesetzt die katholische kirche soll
vermitteln in der hauptstadt quito gilt
wegen der eskalierenden gewalt weiterhin
eine ausgangssperre
auslöser war die streichung der
treibstoff subventionen
sie ist teil der auflagen des iwf für
einen milliardenkredit
im süden mexikos haben 500 beamte der
mexikanischen nationalgarde bis zu 2000
migranten die auf dem weg in die usa
waren zur umkehr gezwungen
die migranten aus afrika der karibik und
zentralamerika hatten sich zu fuß
aufgemacht mexiko hat sich verpflichtet
die grenzen mit national garden zu
besetzen
das hatte us-präsident trank unter
androhung von strafzöllen erzwungen
zum zweiten mal seit dem arabischen
frühling 2011 haben die tunesier einen
neuen präsidenten gewählt
nach ersten prognosen hat der parteilose
juraprofessor said
mit über 72 prozent der stimmen in der
stichwahl einen erdrutschsieg erzielt
damit setzte er sich deutlich gegen den
umstrittenen medienmogul karoui durch
der als erzkonservativ geltenden site
wird demnach die nachfolge des
verstorbenen präsidenten essebsi anderen
seite für worte die todesstrafe und will
homosexualität weiter unter strafe
stellen
die saarländerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer war heute im saarland aber
es war kein heimspiel
es war der deutschlandtag der jungen
union ihre jährliche hauptversammlung
die organist jugendorganisation jugend
ist man da bis 35 hatte der frau
vorsitzenden gleich drei männer als
mögliche konkurrenten um die
kanzlerkandidatur vorgeschaltet und
machten der vorsitzenden jedes recht auf
einen ersten zugriff auf die kandidatur
streitig
mit der initiative diese mächtigste
personalie per urabstimmung zu
entscheiden
das alles bevor sie heute an kann es
wirkt ein bisschen verloren wie annegret
kramp karrenbauer heute so auf der bühne
der jungen union steht das hatte sie vor
zehn monaten nicht erwartet die eigene
partei jugend spricht ihr den ersten
zugriff auf die kanzlerkandidatur ab mit
der forderung nach einer urwahl der
kandidatin oder des kandidaten
wir haben uns in den letzten zehn
monaten auf den weg gemacht ist bei
weitem nicht alles gelungen sagte ich
selbst auch aber wir haben auch vieles
geschafft was vielleicht gar nicht so
sehr gesehen wird zur urwahl idee selbst
sagt sie nicht einfach ignorieren
scheint ihre devise aber sie verteidigt
sich mit dem hinweis auf all das neue
beim thema klimaschutz oder
digitalisiert kramp karrenbauer steht es
ja frei sich auch zu bewerben und sie
hat ja selbst gesagt sie hat sich im
letzten jahr schon in einem
innerparteilichen demokratischen prozess
durchgesetzt von daher muss sie den ja
nicht scheuen
drei tage lang hatte die eu den
konkurrenten der parteivorsitzenden eine
bühne bereitet mancher gab es nicht
loyal mancher verteilte verbale spitzen
aber direkte kritik an ak war nicht zu
hören verstehen uns auch als team auch
die stellvertreter auch das präsidium
ist mit in der pflicht ich cdu nach oben
zu bringen
das darf man nicht alleine bei einer
vorsitzenden ablagen wenn es nur auf die
otto ankäme wäre friedrich merz sicher
der favorit eine rolle die ihm nur
oberflächlich peinlich ist und jens
spahn ist jung genug um noch zu warten
aber auch er sieht dass es nicht rund
läuft sie umfragen sind wie sie sind sie
häufig wir uns im klein-klein
verstricken und uns einen anderen
abarbeiten
wir federn lassen von wahl zu wahl das
lässt euch nicht kalt und das lässt mich
nicht kalt
nur einer hat tatsächlich seinen
verzicht angedeutet
ich persönlich habe lange dafür
gearbeitet und habe meinen glauben job
gefunden
kramp karrenbauers ansehen bei dir tu
leidet unter den letzten monaten und der
riese und dem gebrochenen versprechen
nicht ins kabinett zu gehen dass sie
dafür gegenwind bekommt wusste sie
lasten streiten aber lasst uns nie
vergessen der politische gegner sitzt
immer außerhalb unserer reihen nie
innerhalb der jungen union ist die
stimmung schlecht und die rede war
natürlich war gut
absolut aber das reiche es nicht aus ich
denke nur eine rede kann alles
rauslassen müssen schon taten folgen sie
tritt sehr stark auf zutritt sehr sicher
auf und
deshalb macht sie als parteivorsitzendem
guten job trotz freundlichen geschenken
zum schluss einfach war es heute nicht
aber sie hat klar gemacht dass ihr im
kampf um die macht nicht zurückziehen
zur britischen politik der
straßenkünstler banksy hat das britische
parlament schon zehn jahre vor den
aktuellen brachse debatten als
affenzirkus gesehen so aktuell dass ein
unbekannter bieter dafür jetzt elf
millionen euro zahlte
wie gut für großbritannien dass da immer
noch das symbol steht für eine
majestätische geschichte allerdings muss
die queen wenn es drauf ankommt nach der
pfeife tanzen die der premierminister
spielt auch morgen bei der queen's
speech die die queen zwar sprechen aber
nicht selbst schreiben darf eine
betrachtung unserer korrespondentin am
hofe von sohn james die queen ist alles
andere als amüsiert ihre aufgabe ist es
zu herrschen ohne zu regieren
doch nach 67 jahren in denen sie sich
vornehm zurückgehalten hat aus den
niederungen der politik droht der
premierminister sie und ihre rolle zu
beschädigen
boris johnson habe die queen irre
geleitet so urteilte das oberste gericht
ende september die vorsitzende richterin
entschied
der premier hatte die queen nicht darum
bitten dürfen das parlament mitten in
einer für die nation entscheidenden
phase für fünf wochen aufzuheben
boris hat elisabeth zur komplizin eines
rechtsbruchs gemacht also expect die
königin war sicherlich sehr wenig froh
darüber eine anweisung erteilt zu haben
die sich hinterher als gesetzeswidrig
herausgestellt hat ihr leben lang
verließ sie ihre rolle nur um millimeter
einmal trug sie ein outfit in dem so
mancher eine europafreundliche haltung
sehen wollte und zeigte vor langer zeit
politische leidenschaft beim thema
südafrika
damals äußerte sie regelrecht wut
darüber dass margaret thatcher einen
internationalen boykott des apartheid
regimes nicht unterstützen wollte
nun steht der regentin eine zumutung ins
haus morgen soll sie die queen's speech
halten bei der sie traditionell das
regierungsprogramm für die kommende
legislaturperiode verliest
allein boris johnson will ja so schnell
es geht neuwahlen herbeiführen
greenspan regierungserklärung wird so de
facto zu einer wahlkampfrede für die
konservative partei und damit sind die
drexhage faden der queen womöglich noch
nicht zu ende
das gesetz verlangt von premier johnson
in brüssel um eine verschiebung des
austritts datums zu bitten wenn er bis
zum 19
oktober keinen neuen deal mit eu und
parlament vereinbart hat er selbst sagt
er wurde das auf keinen fall
dann würde das parlament wohl versuchen
ihn zu stürzen wenn die regierung das
vertrauen des parlaments verliert zum
beispiel indem sie ein misstrauensvotum
verliert dann ist die green nicht länger
an den rat der regierung gebunden und
dann hat sie eine art ermessensspielraum
haus player diskussion
ermessensspielraum genau den sollte und
wollte die queen niemals haben der
praxis lässt nichts unangetastet im
königreich noch einmal nach polen wir
haben ja schon gemeldet dass tiefe
europa manchmal recht schwierige und
sperrige pis partei bei den wahlen heute
in polen wieder eine deutliche mehrheit
errungen hat natalie was bedeutet das
nun für polen und was bedeutet es für
europa sieht sogar nach einer absoluten
mehrheit im sam aus das sind zwar nur
nachwahlumfragen aber trotzdem die
tendenz ist da im senat muss man noch
abwarten da hat die pis im moment auch
die absolute mehrheit aber auch damals
die muss man noch abwarten
aber diese deutliche mehrheit diese
vielleicht absolute mehrheit für die pis
das bedeutet dass der umbau des landes
weiter gehen wird das eps durchaus auch
selbst angekündigte justizreform diese
umstrittene soll unbedingt noch weiter
vorangetrieben werden man will noch mehr
politischen einfluss auf die gerichte
kaczynski hat gerade gesagt polen muss
noch verändert werden
es muss noch besser werden wir machen
nichts gefährliches es gibt noch freie
medien in polen
zahlreiche sogar muss man sagen aber
eine medienreform liegt bei der pis in
der schublade
kaczynski hat mal gesagt und daran
erinnern sich viele polen noch sehr gut
er möchte in warschau ein zweites
budapest da kann man sich ungefähr
vorstellen wo die reise hingehen soll
für europa bedeutet das natürlich
verschärfung der konflikte gerade in
sachen justizreform da wird sich der
tonfall sicherlich nach eher verschärfen
als sich abmildern und für die polnische
gesellschaft würde eine absolute
mehrheit bedeuten diese tiefe kluft und
diese spaltung die in diesem land
wirklich überall zu spüren ist das würde
auch nicht weniger werden
wohin jetzt eine demokratie die mehrheit
hat entschieden dankeschön
natalie und es gab auch an diesem
sonntag sport und da eine premiere bei
der ironman-wm auf hawaii
beide sieger grenze gehen an deutsche
triathleten als erste deutsche frau
holte die 36-jährige frenking anne haupt
den titel in dem extrem kampf über 36
kilometer schwimmen 180 kilometer
radfahren und dem marathon auch jan
frodeno feiert nicht nur den sieg
sondern eine premiere als erster
deutscher hat der 38 jährigen kölner den
legendären ironman heute zum dritten mal
gewonnen
nach 2015 16 mercedes-pilot valtteri
bottas hat den großen preis von japan
gewonnen und sein team vorzeitig die
konstrukteurs weltmeisterschaft zum
sechsten mal in folge
der finne siegte vor sebastian vettel im
ferrari
in seinem teamkollegen lewis hamilton
damit ist sicher auch in der
fahrerwertung geht der titel an einen
der beiden silberpfeil piloten beim
nächsten lauf in mexiko könnte hamilton
seinen sechsten wm sieg perfekt machen
deutschlands bester tennisspieler
alexander zverev hat das finale des atp
masters in shanghai klar verloren 4 zu 6
und 1 zu 6 gegen den russen daniil mit
wege bei der turn-wm in stuttgart hat
sich die amerikanerin simon beils im
mehrkampf den fünften wm-titel gesichert
die viermalige olympiasiegerin hat am
boden mit einem triple-double einem
doppel salto mit dreifacher schraube und
am schwebebalken den ersten platz belegt
die 22 jährige geht mit 25 wm medaillen
als erfolgreichste turnerin aller zeiten
beste deutsche am schwebebalken war
sarah voss auf platz sieben
[Applaus]
auf uns folgt gleich die verleihung der
großen preise für klassische musik
früher echo inzwischen opus klassik
jedenfalls sind die besten ihres fachs
zusammen
claudio armbruster hat während der
proben in berlin drei von ihnen
getroffen die zeigen wie sehr das
klassische fach etwas für junge künstler
ist und er hat sie gefragt was ihnen zum
großen alten meister 1 beethoven 2020
wird sein jahr das muss man schon feiern
schließlich wird beethoven ja nur einmal
250 und wo sonst hat man die möglichkeit
so viele klassische musiker beethoven
hochleben zu lassen wie auf einer
preisverleihung
fangen wir an mit andreas ottensamer
ausgezeichnet als instrumentalist des
jahres spielt für uns was aus beethovens
gassenhauer trio wieder offen für mich
steht einerseits für unfassbare japan
fortschritt für seine zeit fast bekannte
art zu komponieren für damalige zeiten
und gleichzeitig verbindet er das mit
einer ungemeinen perfektion von seiner
systematik in seiner kompositionstechnik
dass er einfach unangreifbar ist und
diese kombination ist natürlich sehr
stark
sol gabetta instrumentalistin des jahres
mit einem ausschnitt aus beethovens
tripelkonzert
[Musik]
ich finde er war sicher auch jemand der
viel revolutionär dafür seinerseits war
halt jemand dass sich getraut hat so zu
schreiben wir schreiben will und nicht
zu schreiben nur was er schreiben muss
für die regener mann und so hat auch die
bevölkerung dieser musik gehört diese
musik akzeptieren müssen damals
vielleicht weil es vielleicht einige
auch schockieren gewissen ist aber seine
musik ist bis heute noch aktuell
modern und konstantin reinfeldt bekommt
den opus klassik als nachwuchskünstler
beethovens violinkonzert auf der
mundharmonika
[Musik]
ludwig van beethoven stellt ja auch
schon bisher so den übergang zur
romantik da und das ist was für mich der
an tollen harmonien und jazzigen
harmonien interessiert ist was total
spannendes nur ein kleiner vorgeschmack
auf ein großes beethoven jahr
[Musik]
so endet die woche des journals aufs
schönste was die neue bringen kann
verpackt ralf panne check kompakt die
entscheidende phase beginnt bei der
langen suche der spd nach einer neuen
parteispitze ab montag dürfen die über
430.000 spd-mitglieder nun wählen wen
sie wollen wem sie ihre stimme geben
das kandidatenfeld hat sich
zwischenzeitlich etwas gelichtet nur
noch sechs duos stehen zur wahl
23 mal hatten die sich in bewerber
schoss vorgestellt einen favoriten gibt
es nicht bis zum 25
oktober läuft die abstimmung
die luft wird immer dünner ab donnerstag
haben die eu staats und regierungschefs
in brüssel ihr herz treffen zwei tage
aber vor allem ein thema der nahende
braig city bigge frage gibt es den
austritt großbritanniens ende oktober
wenn ja mit oder ohne vertrag oder wird
alles verschoben
überraschend hatte sich der britische
premier johnson mit airlines
ministerpräsidenten getroffen und
seitdem ist zumindest etwas in bewegung
geraten ausgang offen
das geschriebene wort steht in frankfurt
vier tage lange mittelpunkt am mittwoch
beginnt die buchmesse gastland in diesem
jahr norwegen einreise aber auch ein
leseland keine steuern auf bücher
gezielte leseförderung zahlreiche
autoren stipendien norwegische autoren
schreiben viel spannendes nachdenkliches
warnendes vorneweg der große alte mann
der norwegischen literatur ist ein gott
und das herbstwetter bringt zu
wochenbeginn sonne und wärme ab mittwoch
wird es dann überall wechselhaft
morgen gibt es viel sonne bei 21 bis 26
grad nur im norden wird es etwas
frischer
und dort gibt es teils dichte wolken und
etwas regen die weiteren aussichten eine
mischung aus sonne und wolken und ein
paar schauern dienstag noch sehr warm
danach wurde es etwas kühler
morgen wird christian sievers dieser
stelle hier begleiten wir begleiten wir
werden mal schauen ob wir das sakko von
constantin reinfeldt aus berlin
rechtzeitig bis dahin hierher bringen
zweifellos elegant neben kaiser
berichtet eine gute woche ernannt
[Musik]